J'ai vendu je pense à environ trois millions
d'exemplaires dans le monde qu'est-ce que
tu penses chaque matin quand tu
me vois dans le miroir
oh je pense
bien tu vieillis et tu
es ta mâchoire devient beaucoup
plus lourde tu sais que tu avais l'habitude d'avoir un
différent  visage et puis ça
change tout le temps tu sais juste au moment où
je me suis habitué à la façon dont c'était maintenant ça
change encore
c'est ce que je pense que
changerais-tu en toi si tu avais le
Magic Touch
je serais plus confiant je pense que je
pense que je bougerais plus sur scène qui
admirais-tu quand tu étais enfant
quand j'étais adolescent j'admirais
Leonard Cohen parce qu'il était très
indépendant et il semblait écrire des chansons
qu'il voulait écrire et partir en tournée
quand  il voulait partir en tournée sans
penser à être populaire ou à
faire des choses que d'autres personnes voulaient qu'il
fasse quand et où avez-vous vu Lou
Reed sur scène et que vous a-t-il apporté
J'ai vu Lou Reed sur scène
en 1979 à  Columbia University euh
et ça m'a amené à l'idée que
je pouvais enfin écrire des chansons sans mélodie
ou sans refrain, je pouvais écrire des chansons de ma
propre vie à New York et je n'avais pas
à faire en sorte que les gens chantent
avec toi  savoir dans le circuit folk donc cela
m'a apporté une toute nouvelle façon d'écrire
des chansons combien d'exemplaires de solitude
standing avez-vous vendus dans le monde
entier j'ai vendu je pense environ trois
millions d'exemplaires dans le monde
[Musique]
quelle a été la principale source d'inspiration pour votre
troisième album jours de  main ouverte
principalement les thèmes de ce troisième
album sont les rêves tournés vers l'
avenir
et la vie quotidienne telle qu'elle était dans les
deux derniers après le succès de Luca avez-vous
évité le piège d'écrire sur la drogue
l'inceste et le suicide des adolescents
oui et non j'ai écrit  à propos du suicide sur
mon nouvel album bien que je ne pense pas que ce soit
un piège ce n'est pas ce n'est pas comme Luca c'est
un autre genre de chanson
n'était-ce pas parfois difficile à produire
avec Anton senko et fait bien travailler et aimer
c'est la première fois que je  on m'a
posé cette question
euh
oui parfois c'était tu sais que c'est
difficile de travailler avec quelqu'un
avec qui tu es impliqué parfois parce que
quand si tu te sens en colère il n'y a pas d'endroit où
tu peux aller tu sais mais pour la
plupart ça a très bien marché  parce que
nous sommes très différents et que nous
nous complétons donc ce que je fais bien il ne le
fait pas et puis ce qu'il fait bien je ne le fais pas
quelle a été la contribution de Philip
Glass sur cet album Philip Glass a écrit un
arrangement de cordes pour  une chanson qui s'appelle 50
50 chance qui parle d'
une tentative de suicide alors comment
fais-tu pour écrire des chansons tout en faisant le tour du
monde pour des concerts ou une promotion euh
je ne les écris que quand je suis à la maison donc
je prends du temps
c'est en partie pour ça  il s'est passé beaucoup de temps
entre le dernier album et cet album
j'ai beaucoup de mal à écrire
quand je suis sur la route tu as dit que
depuis Solitude debout tu as retrouvé
ton père biologique et que sa
mère était batteuse
euh  bon voyons euh ouais quand j'étais en
tournée en 1987 j'ai embauché un détective pour retrouver
mon père biologique que je n'avais pas vu
depuis que j'étais bébé
et je savais aussi qu'il avait été adopté donc je
ne pensais pas qu'il allait avoir  aucune
information sur sa propre mère et son
père et puis quand je lui ai parlé, il
s'est avéré que sa mère avait été
batteuse dans un groupe de jazz dans les années 30 et
qu'elle avait été sur la route
euh
donc il semble que même si nous n'avons jamais
su  l'autre comme une famille avec laquelle la
comédie musicale The Musical
Talent a été transmise par la
famille même si nous ne nous connaissions pas et à
propos de Paris j'aime Paris je m'y
habitue
euh
j'ai eu des expériences étranges ici